[Musik]
ich bin über latein amerika nach
deutschland gekommen bis zum nächsten
flug nach deutschland wusste ich nicht
was ich fühlen sollte ich habe nur
versucht zu überleben
die reise dauerte ungefähr zehn stunden
im flugzeug würde mir klar in welche
situation geraten bin ich voll
[Musik]
ich glaube nicht an grenzen
jede sozial sein
[Musik]
wie kann ich überhaupt angrenzend jahren
mein land ist da nicht durch grenzen in
vier teile gespalten
jetzt bin ich in deutschland und ich
denke meine deutsche staat mich nicht
akzeptiert dann will ich ja auch nicht
hier sein
auch menschen im alltag
die halt
sid
den gesamten tag über fühlte ich mich
kurz davor in tränen auszubrechen
jedoch habe ich mich gefasst
ich versuchte stark zu sein
ich musste stark sein ich hatte angst
zur polizei zu gehen
trotzdem habe ich mich an den polizisten
gewandt da seine arbeit gemacht hat
meine stimme zitterte und ich sagte 'ich
möchte asyl beantragt ich dachte sie
hätten das recht nicht zu verhaften
wieso weiß ich nicht ich hatte nichts
falsch gemacht
in diesem moment verlor ich meine würde
ich war geflohen um nicht eingesperrt zu
werden
und hier schließt sich es widerstandlos
zu ich entschuldige mich als die
polizistin meine schmutzigen sachen
anfasst um sage es war eine lange reise
sie sagt ich bin daran gewöhnt
warum versuche ich konversation
betreiben weiß ich nicht vielleicht
möchte ich dass sie weiß dass ich
normalerweise sauber bin
es ist so dumm aber ich entschuldige
mich immer wieder bei der polizei
nach langen jahren des widerstandes
müssen sich politische gefangene in
türkischen gefängnissen bei einer
körperlichen untersuchung nicht mehr
nackt ausziehen
deshalb wurde ich noch nie gezwungen
meine kleidung im gefängnis auszusehen
selbst als ich in der türkei aufgrund
meiner politischen tätigkeit als kurden
inhaftiert wurde ist mir das nicht
passiert
[Musik]
die polizistin sagt du musst deine und
als ich beginne meine unterwäsche aus
zusehen kann ich mich nicht mehr halten
in mir brennt etwas einsturz schmitz ich
versuche mir einzureden dass nach seien
normal ist in diesem moment ist das eine
sehr verzweifelt gedanke als ob es nur
um das leben von kleidung gehe ich habe
geweint
die polizistin war ein guter milch sie
hat gewartet was ich gemeint habe
ich meine und ich gehorche befehle
ich weine nicht weil ich mich meiner
nacktheit schäme
ich weine weil mein herz völlig nackt
ist ihr vorname wird ist vornamen
sie ist blond
denn hier hat
damals hatte ich einen großen streit mit
eine wärterin weil sie verlangt hatte
dass ich meine schuhe aussehen hier im
trend im land mit dem wissen dass sich
mein privilegierten status als
staatsbürgerin verloren hatte fürchte
ich mich nicht stark genug um eine
haltung zu bewahren
jetzt will ich in deutschland aber nicht
wie ein vogel
ich bin wie ein getrocknetes blatt dass
seinem baum verloren hat ich habe hier
keine virtual es ist kalt unter findest
stark ich muss mit einem nackten seele
hier sein
[Musik]